Senator Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
shared a close friendship with John
McCain for more than 20 years from the
halls of the Senate to the campaign
trail to nearly 50 overseas trips to war
zones their bond was a rarity in
rancorous Congress we spoke to Senator
Graham about John McCain's legacy the
White House Counsel and the mauler
investigation
if you back in the Senate could pass
some legislation not not to honor him or
his building and what would you pass
what would you try and get past the
immigration I want to get that down
because it meant a lot to John to fix a
broken immigration system president can
do this he is a deal maker but the
people around him not so much people
would say the the real disconnect
between your effort to try to work with
the president and your friendship with
John McCain is people say all the praise
that's being heaped on John McCain does
not apply to the president I am going to
do everything I can to help president
Trump and when he's wrong I will say so
it bothers me greatly when the president
says things about John McCain it pisses
me off to no end and I let the president
know it the way he's handled that the
passing of a John is just was disturbing
we finally got it right I am NOT going
to give up on the idea of working with
this president the best way I can honor
John McCain has helped my country did
you call a president and tell him to
bring the flag back down to half-staff
no but I call some people around him
what could the president learn from John
McCain what I would tell the president
you've got a lot of people you think are
treating you unfairly fight back but
you're gonna have to be a big man in a
big office John McCain was a big man
worthy of a big country mr. president
you need to be the big man that the
presidency requires some people worry
that getting rid of magan means fewer
people around him reminding him of the
constraints of the presidency remind him
to be a big man what you suggested then
that as long as I'm around I'll remind
him of how this game played I've been
pumped into Pietschmann of Clinton I
understand the process pretty well
here's what I'll tell the president
there is no scenario where you can end
this investigation the mulher
investigation
through some political intrigue and
survived that's the end of you the only
person in America that can clear Donald
Trump is moer do you think he'd fire
Attorney General Sessions today if he
could I think he wants an attorney
general but he has a better working
relationship with and to those in my
business who say you're stuck with Jeff
Sessions I like Jeff Sessions but I mean
oh yeah how smart you have to be to
understand this this is not working let
me ask you about the mall investigation
you said that at the end of the day if
there is collusion between the Trump
campaign and the Russians that'll be it
for me anything else will be just noise
yeah but you said you have faith in
Muller
so if mother finds something else and
it's not collusion but then he'll act on
it I say this is a joke but it's kind of
a half of a joke to collude you got to
sit down come up with a plan and stick
with it Trump's not good at that
but Lindsey Graham recognizes that an
investigation may start here and
ultimately be cause for a hundred
percent so that could be possible in
that but we'll see what he finds
absolutely we'll have more of our
interview with Senator Lindsey Graham in
our next hour ahead he'll take us inside
their unique friendship and their final
moments together